all right today we're going to be
talking about data networks you've heard
of networks before maybe a water network
or road network even a television
network or a cell phone network today
we're talking about data networks which
are the networks that computers use the
three types we're going to cover in this
video are the local area network the
wide area network and the Virtual
Private Network a local area network is
just a small group of computers that are
connected together the most important
thing about a local area network is that
those computers are close together so
your Wi-Fi it Starbucks or at a school
that is the local area network that you
can only connect to if you're actually
close to that a wide area network is two
local area networks that have been
connected over a long distance so maybe
a school in Colorado wants to connect
with the school in Missouri they could
use a wide area network you might think
that those are connected over the
internet and in the case of a virtual
private network which accomplishes
basically the same thing as a wide area
network it is VPNs use the Internet to
connect their two local area networks
however a wide area network will usually
rent a cable from an Internet company
and connect that way so just to review a
local area network is a group of
computers connected close to each other
a wide area network in a virtual private
network are two local area networks or
more that have been connected over long
distances the wide area network
accomplishes this by renting a line from
an Internet company and a virtual
private network does it over the
Internet